okay first question from Ashley at
queasy big how do I know if I have the
stomach flu or a hangover well honey did
you drink last night mmm glug glug did
you have food or did you have alcohol
the Internet is not for stupidity ma'am
the Internet is for smart established
doctors like me and my friend Luis here
think before you tweet greetings
greetings Bill Nye here are Jim Cameron
here so I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson former
NASA astronaut scott kelly hi I'm Anna
this is dr. ken Jong today I'm gonna
answer some of your questions on Twitter
you ever wonder what happens to your
your organs in space like other
floats around do your organs float
around your body or that everything
floats including your guts you can feel
that I mean you could feel like your
insides don't feel quite normal certain
you know processes that we have to deal
with every day particularly you know
using the restroom our body likes to
have gravity telling us which direction
to push stuff create some challenges if
aliens exist how do I know I'm not one
you're probably not an alien because you
share all the same organs in the same
place with the same biochemistry and
highly common DNA with the person
sitting across from you and everyone
else walking this earth you have DNA in
common with yeast cells with an apple
with oak trees so that's some of the
best evidence we know that you yourself
are not an alien
bohemian my ass is it possible to punch
yourself in the brain so that you just
forget certain memories and stuff like
that I wish it was actually forgetting
is very adaptive it's very useful it
would be terrible to remember everything
in fact some people with really really
good memories have a lot of problems in
their lives because they simply can't
forget so is there a way to just get rid
of particular memories and we're not
quite there yet
but there's some interesting work in
just with mice at the moment that shows
that it is possible
certain memories from mice whether that
will also apply to humans or not there's
a long way down the road but don't punch
yourself in the brain that's not gonna
do it official beer eh all right what
the is a tractor beam and why does every
sci-fi film have one well I actually
haven't made a sci-fi film yet that has
tractor beam in it but a tractor beam is
mythical technology or you can reach out
with some invisible force and grab
something and pull it to you the tractor
beam is obviously a technology we don't
have but there is this little thing
called coal flux pinning by the way when
you have a type two super conductor in a
powerful magnetic field you get this
thing called the Meissner effect which
means that you can actually lock on to
it and hold it in place and manipulate
that's a tractor beam in a sense that
works over a very short distance so
maybe we'll be able to figure out a
tractor beam
rocki online I have a doubt related to
evolution theory if we evolved from
monkeys then why are there still monkeys
haha that's brilliant you're the first
guy to ever wonder this we did not
descend from monkeys monkeys and we have
a common ancestor so you may have seen
this picture this famous arrangement
this isn't really accurate it wasn't
just one to the other to the other as we
say the the family tree of hominids like
you and me and even my old boss haha
it's not just a straight line of one
organism leading to another it's a bush
as we say so there's many many branches
and you and I ended up on one of them
and so we do not descend for monkeys
monkeys and us have a common ancestor
and you can prove it at dr. Clair cane
says help need emergency hiccup cure
before clinic starts in approximately
five minutes steep scare Jim all right
at life's to piss why is my eye
twitching oh my god stop first of all
probably stop using words like oh my god
stop maybe get some more sleep drink
less caffeine all right next yokomo at
yossi flow one three one five seven zero
one two writes
I have no pinky toe nail it was this
evolution you'll notice that in
evolution was an interesting thing a
fascinating thing a very important idea
oh c'mon you don't have to be any better
than you have to be this is to say there
is no force no natural force no natural
selecting pressure tap superpowers to
have x-ray vision to be able to run
faster than a speeding locomotive or
leap tall buildings in a single bound
there's no motivation for that so if
you're able to live your life put on
shoes run marathons whatever you might
do dance swing dances maybe the Balboa
or the collegiate shag or East Coast
Swing you can do all that without a
toenail
there's no evolutionary pressure for you
to get one and you know what else yokomo
I'll bet you really have one it's just
the nail beds really small carry on if
the higgs-boson etc forms an essential
part of reality which it does why can't
it be found in our front room or all
around us there's certain parts of our
fundamental reality that you only gain
access to under certain conditions of
pressure and temperature and energy you
don't experience a proton in your life
but it's a fundamental part of nuclei
that make up the atoms that comprise
your body so just because you don't see
it feel it touch it taste it or smell it
does not mean it does not exist and part
of the entire purpose of why we have
science at all in particular the methods
and tools of science is to decode that
which is true about nature that
otherwise transcends your sensory
perceptions that is what science is you
wouldn't need the tools if our brains
sensory system accurately decoded the
world around us but it doesn't and
that's why science tries to find any way
it can to remove your brain ie R nose
mouth touch from the operation and the
more we can successfully do it the less
bias shows up in the result just get the
human out of it so yeah reality is not
what you perceive it's what the methods
and tools of science reveal